GOING AWAY SO THE QUESTIONS WILL
COME COMING.
MANU, THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> >>> FIRST HERE ON CNN, TOP
REPUBLICANS ARE INVESTIGATING
THE U.S. CHAOTIC WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
ON THURSDAY, COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
MICHAEL McCAUL REQUESTED THE
STATE DEPARTMENT HAND OVER A
VAST NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO THE EXIT.
>> THE AGENCY NOW HAS LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS TO RESPOND.
IF IT DOES NOT COMPLY,
CONGRESSMAN McCAUL HAS
THREATENED THE POWER OF THE
SUBPOENA.
CNN NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT KYLIE ATWOOD IS AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THIS
MORNING.
THIS IS EXPECTED AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS TO BE ANSWERED
ABOUT HOW THIS WITHDRAWAL CAME
ABOUT.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE PACE
OF THIS AND WHEN STARTS AND HOW
LONG IT WILL GO AND HOW FAR IT
WILL GO.
>> LISTEN, IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
LETTER SENT FROM THIS CHAIRMAN
OF THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
COMMITTEE, CONGRESSMAN McCAUL TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE, IT IS
CLEAR THAT THE COMMITTEE WANTS
TO INVESTIGATE ESSENTIALLY EVERY
ASPECT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT THEY HAVE REQUESTED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT IS A LIST OF ALL
OF THE PLANNING, ALL OF THE
MEETINGS THAT WENT INTO THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
THEY WANT A LIST OF ALL OF THE
U.S. TALIBAN MEETINGS DURING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, AND THEY
ALSO ARE MAKING IT VERY CLEAR
THEY WANT TO LOOK AT THE
AFTER-EFFECTS OF THE WITHDRAWAL.
SO THEY WANT A STATUS UPDATE ON
THE AFGHANS WHO HAVE COME HERE
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
FUTURE OF U.S. SECURITY
ASSISTANCE, U.S. ASSISTANCE
GENERALLY TO AFGHANISTAN IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
SO THEY'RE CASTING A BROAD
STROKE HERE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY WANT FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, WHAT THEY ARE
LOOKING INTO.
THIS IS A TEN-PAGE LETTER.
AS YOU SAID, THIS IS EXPECTED.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT KNEW THAT
CONGRESSMAN McCAUL WAS GOING TO
BE LAUNCHING THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY SAY THAT THEY LOOK FORWARD
ENGAGING WITH CONGRESS.
THEY HAVEN'T SAYING THEY'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE ALL OF THESE
DOCUMENTS, SO THAT IS GOING TO
BE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO WATCH FOR
HERE.
HOW MUCH DOES THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WORK WITH THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
COMMITTE